good morning everyone
i'm your host for today morning my name
is michelle representing the design
singapore council
thank you for taking time out to join us
in this morning's webinar
design thinking for business
transformation in the fmb space
so today's session is brought to you by
design singapore council
the national agency for design in
singapore and the national design center
so this webinar is part of the national
design center's program lineup in august
with a dramatic focus on singapore our
home
we'll share more again on this month's
program lineup at the end of this
session
with stiff competition and rising costs
for labor as well as rental
fmb business owners need more than just
an innovative food concept
to survive in this session we'll be
hearing from the owners of two homegrown
f fmb companies on how they've used
design thinking
to help rapidly transform and rethink
their business
so for now just some house rules before
we get to start off proper
if you encounter any technical issues
please
reach out to our technical team through
the zoom chat function
we'll ask for your patience and
understanding should the conditions be
less than perfect
during this webinar your audio will be
on the mute mode
however we welcome questions throughout
the session please keep your questions
coming in
through the zoom q a function when
posting a question
please help to identify yourself and
indicate if you would like
a specific panelist to answer your
question
for now i'd like to introduce our
speakers as well as our moderators for
this morning
we're very honored to be able to invite
mr adrian debae
co-founder and managing director of
salad stop to speak about the use of
experience design in a post-covet wall
having grown up in the hospitality
industry in asia
adrian and his father felt a need for
healthier food options in singapore
in 2009 so this escalated into a vision
of bringing something innovative
fresh and tasty to increasingly
discerning and
health conscious people today salad stop
operates
over 50 outlets across singapore
hong kong vietnam malaysia
japan korea indonesia and spain
adrian is also a cornell university
graduate
and worked as a consultant in the
hospitality industry for many years
he has most recently held the position
of vice president
development and acquisitions with
kingdom hotel investments
spearheading all investment
opportunities for the group in china
so next we have mr steen pugo currently
an
investor and also the former ceo of four
fingers
who will be sharing with us about
designing a brand experience and how
that is so
important for businesses steen was the
ceo of four fingers
crispy chicken between 2013
uh to 2018. starting with just one store
he set the business on the path to rapid
sustained profitable growth
after stepping down from his position he
moved to private equity with a focus on
acquisitions in southeast asia's fmb
sector
so steen's career has focused on brands
f b
and franchising he believes in always
putting the customer first
and connecting with consumers through
brand experiences
he recognizes the need to constantly
innovate disrupt
and challenge the status quo in order to
ensure a brand and its business model
remains relevant to its customers
steen also sits on the board of domino's
pizza
in the philippines as well as the
advisory board of the institute of
service excellence
he remains a shareholder at four fingers
last but not least we have our moderator
mr hong kai singh
founder of studio dojo who will be
facilitating the panel discussion later
in this session
kaising has been in the design field
since 2004 focusing on design
research and interaction design he was
previously the head of singapore for
food proof
a uk-based experience design agency he's
a firm believer
in holistic experience design spending
digital
spatial product and service domains
however he also thinks that delivering
great design for client is only
part of the equation it is also key to
help clients bring sustained impact
and cultural change in the work they do
and since fourth
after leaving foo proof he went on to
set up studio dojo where he focuses
on training coaching and advising
individual designers
helping teams and leaders from
organizations build internal
capabilities
for design and creative work his own
goal
is to enable this teams to acquire
capabilities on their own
and sustain the innovation in the
process in the long run
all right so now i'll hand the time over
to adrian
to start this session proper eden please
okay thank you michelle and design
singapore for giving me the opportunity
and to speak today
um and just to share some insight i
guess on what we've gathered over the
last few years in terms of design
thinking
um and also i guess some of our thoughts
moving forward in this uh post-covet
world
so let me just share my slides with all
of you
okay
all right um so let me start off just
giving you a very brief uh
introduction on the company um some of
you might know solid stop
but you might have not come across our
sister brands
um salad stop started 11 years ago
and really with the intention at that
point to provide a healthier option so
we were really looking to just
um fulfill a need in the market which
was uh
really lacking any kind of healthy
option and
any sort of form of a good salad um and
after a few years i think when
especially we looked at
reimagining our store designs and our
menus and
and just trying to expand so beyond the
cbd at that point
um that evolved into creating a movement
uh built around
sort of ecosystems and communities um
and i'll explain a little bit more about
you know the transition we did from
i guess our first um store to you know
the second version um and now moving
forward
really we're you know we have a dream of
creating a new generation of transparent
tech enabled health
brands with the utmost respect for the
environment
um so in terms of the three brands that
form part of the portfolio now um we
have wushi which is a sort of a
mucky role concept focused very much on
kind of a younger audience
and we would sort of consider that
lifestyle healthy uh hebrew which we
know
launched in september last year uh which
is a warm green bowl concept
and we would consider that as feel good
healthy and then salad stop
uh i'm assuming a few of you are aware
of that's really functional healthy
and we we really push the boundaries a
little bit more
on the nutritional side of things uh but
all three brands really
um have an overarching principle of
health and really
you know sort of showcasing that healthy
food doesn't need to be boring
or tasteless and and every one of the
brands really offers a lot of
personalization so you can customize
pretty much anything
salad stop up to today is in fifth in
eight markets
with 55 outlets um we opened our first
international location in the
philippines
six years ago and have been sort of
growing ever since
so to give you a sense of what the dead
stein evolution was like
um version 1.0 was really just a
homemade
uh we bought some graphics off the
internet
and put it together um you know my
father and i
had some experience obviously in the
hospitality sector but
um we were venturing into the farts food
space and
um we we had to do this on a budget
obviously we opened three
we signed three locations before opening
the first one so we really felt there
was an opportunity
and a gap in the market but we had to
keep costs low and and
we launched you know with our original
design uh
in uh marina square in 2009
um about six years after that we
started working with ong on version 2.0
um and a big part of that was also just
asking ourselves
you know what we stand for where do we
see ourselves what resonates with
customers the customers
also started asking us a lot more
questions about where our food was from
and just became a lot more educated
about the product we were offering
and that's where we really felt we
needed to sort of convey the message of
what we believed in and what
differentiated us
along the way and especially over the
last five years as we've grown
internationally
we had to adapt the concept not just uh
to the local
taste buds but also adding some design
elements which just suited
the local market so in every market we
then worked with local designers to
tweak
um the the positioning and the
um and the design but always keeping in
mind you know what the
dna of the brand was and making sure
that we didn't deviate too much from
some of the elements that we originally
had developed
in version 2.0 um the picture on the top
right
is solid stop in indonesia we've got 15
outfits there
doing very well and and there we really
actually had to position it in a
in a slightly more premium position and
really looking at
creating more of a lifestyle brand
rather than singapore which is
probably a little bit more on the on the
fast food side of things
and in hong kong we opened that about
two and a half years ago and that's
actually our own operation
um and we have three stores there and we
also
um changed the design quite a bit more
from an operational perspective where we
created an online pickup shelf and the
biggest change
there was actually creating a customer
facing salad bar
where you you know you would be used to
in singapore but we also built
was we built a back of the house salad
bar so
that back of the house alba is really
just to handle online orders and in hong
kong we do
close to 50 of all of our business
online um and 25
of those of all transactions come
through our own app so
we really built that with the mindset
that we were going to move our business
online hong kong
you know were very tech savvy and um we
we needed
the capacity um to handle that volume
both online and offline
version 3.0 was just about the beginning
this year
um we had quite a few exciting plans for
salad stock um
covid threw all of that up in the air
but also in many ways
um cemented the ideas that we had
and also offered a lot more
thoughts on on you know what will be
important moving forward in terms of
design so i'll go through some of some
of those thoughts
uh but also to give you a sense of um
what we what we have been working on
just to give you a
just a little snippet we also um open
able
like i said um in september last year
and this was already a transition of
where we would see salesforce 3.0 uh
move so um you know ordering kiosks um
we have forging kiosks 60
of all transactions happen on the kiosk
um we
we've integrated every point of sales
into one common printer so for the team
in the back actually they receive the
order
no matter if it's come um from an online
portal through the kiosk or through the
pos
um they don't really need to think
beyond that they just look at this order
slip
they run it through the line so
incredibly efficient and and we really
um luckily had solid stop as a base to
learn from
uh and position this with a slightly
lower price point because we actually
achieved such amazing efficiencies with
our operation there
um that we were able to drive down the
price and actually appeal to a much
wider audience
um so in terms of learnings from covid
obviously 70 of our business
is cbd focused or i guess relying on
office clusters
uh the cbd even up to now is very quiet
um but we have transformed some of those
outlets into cloud kitchens
and really focused on delivering
our product to people working from home
um so that that's obviously a trend that
we
see staying um we don't know up to what
point
um but we've also seen you know a lot of
people becoming home chefs
um sourdough i started a big thing um
healthier options as well um so we think
we're well positioned but we definitely
need to transform our business
to make sure that we reach out to
customers wherever they are
um the emergence of third-party
logistics providers so that was a big
thing that we learned through this whole
period
um we did not need to just rely on the
big deliverables panda and grab
la la move ninja van became really
strong players and we were sort of
forced to work with them
and actually do a huge amount of
business with them right now through our
own
um stock delivery um i think the
economic
climate obviously is is very challenging
right now so we do see people tightening
their belt
so i think we will also need to be very
careful on how
we continue positioning ourselves over
the next few months and maybe some
products that we need to push out a
little bit more to
um maybe not be kind of a premium fast
food but just
you know something that is kind of a
really everyday use for everyone
um as we are very cbd focused we also
need to look
at uh you know the real estate
optimization over the next few years
uh if people are going to work from home
more often we will need to move into
those neighborhoods
and that really puts into question um
what happens to a lot of our stores in
the cbd
and then the business economics i think
we've for a long time
debated and grappled with landlords on
the rental structures
moving forward as we move more over our
business online that comes with heavy
costs
but also i think the value
of a physical space is also put into
question
so i think the the the discussions we
have now are definitely a lot more open
and a lot more
based on reality because uh we will just
not be able to pay the same amount of
rental when
50 60 of our business is online so i
think that is a
reality for landlords now um and
something where the
the p l basically has to start shifting
uh in a more equitable direction
so during covid we also
tested a lot of things we had excess
capacity we had closed half of our
outlets during the circuit breaker
um a lot of our business then shifted to
some of the outlets
in malls which we were very fortunate
for um and online so
we then um just launched a few things
and i'll just mention the ones that
didn't work
um so you also know that we we tried a
lot of things
some did stick some didn't the ones that
didn't stick
were breakfast kits we felt that to
increase our basket size people would be
willing to you know kind of prepare a
little breakfast the next morning that
didn't work uh bundles kids meals for
some reason
none of our brands kind of work with
bundles um so we
still sort of trying to figure that out
and then i think discounts so this was
becoming a very discount heavy
market and we tried a little bit but we
realized that you know
we we did have a very loyal base and we
just had to kind of
go after them and try to make sure we
were top of mind
um the things that did work um and i'll
go through some of these initiatives and
sort of tie it all together in terms of
how this
will impact our store designs but um
solid stock market we launched about
four months ago um
in a very beta phase still up to this
point but i think
obviously learning a lot of things and
we definitely see quite a bit of
traction on a few fronts
uh one of the is healthy meals
come into 10-15 minutes we provide you
basically
pastes pre-cooked items products that
are really easy to combine and that we
might be able to just add on to a few
items that you have at home so we really
obviously see people more and more now
press the time
they still based at home cooking for the
family um but
still looking for help a healthy option
so um we have
added a lot of content now to the
website and we'll continue to do that
uh and also starting to work with local
influencers
and chefs on creating paste for them so
they don't have the capacity to
uh obviously produce these pastes in
bulk
uh and to be aba certified et cetera so
we then leverage off of our central
kitchen to produce their recipes for
them
um and then upsell and cross-sell all
the products that we have on the market
to
hopefully bring you a different
experience so this was a
collaboration we did with paul foster
and his mom
looking at really bringing back a lot of
old piranha recipes
and modernizing them and also adding
obviously a lot of healthy elements like
the impossible random
we are also teaming up with tinoc tino
is also a very avid passionate chef in
singapore
um has a lot of different recipes and
and has always wanted to do this and
so we're teaming up with him on
launching three new tastes
later this year we also launched
something solid stop connect
um so just to give you a sense you know
we we have been investing in our own
technology for very long time
and we built the website connect.com.sg
in about a week
and really off the back of
a delivery fleet that we were building
during cobit
um but also something where we started
hearing from a lot of
office workers that you know they didn't
have the chance to connect
and meet up for lunch anymore so what we
did is
we offered them an option to just fill
in the email addresses of all of your
colleagues
you can check out each of them receives
an individual
voucher and then they use that to
check out and have the items delivered
to them just before their
meeting time or their zoo calls so a
very simple
um solution for us actually to build um
but i think
you know it really was sort of thinking
outside the box and and offering
something
that people were used to when they went
to the office but
now sitting at home they could do this
virtually
so you can visit the website and have a
look
and then lastly one of the big
fundamental changes in our business is
really opening our first cloud kitchen
concept
so when we started delivering island
wide in march
with the liveroom we started seeing all
the distribution points and basically
where people lived
and we saw that a large concentration of
that was in
around the east coast and so when we
started digging a little bit further
we started seeing that dominoes pizza
hut and deliberate editions
all were located on one street and we we
continued um
researching that and we really found out
that that was the optimum
location in terms of delivery radius to
capture most of
of at least our target target audience
in the east we knew how much we were
delivering to that area already
uh and just with those deliveries
uh we could already break even based on
the rentals that we were finding in that
area so
i think we we we learned
we optimized and then when we found this
location in uh
tanjong katong we were able to bring
together
four of our brands and and sushi is
actually a new virtual brand that we
launched
in from the salad stock outlets um and
we are now able to combine them all in
one menu so for customers you're
actually
able to order a mucky roll a grain ball
a smoothie bowl in one order uh and it
gets delivered to you island-wide
so this is the location in carton so if
any of you live in the east this is a
nice healthy option now
uh we've been running this for about two
weeks and seeing some really promising
results
we don't have much of a facing
storefront so it's really very
focused on just the cloud kitchen but we
were able to reuse some of the old
equipment
from previous outlets and get this up
and running within
two and a half weeks so this is my last
slide
and and really i guess the most
important one for today um
what what we've learned over the last um
few
few months i think have definitely
reinforced a lot of the design thinking
that we've been going through over the
last few years
um one of the ones i guess that
we we've we've seen and especially again
very apparent during covert is is
creating unique experiences so i think
you know as people are now able to go
back to restaurants
i think they they definitely look
forward to that experience
in store um and that is really a
challenge for fmp operators to continue
elevating that experience so i think the
pressure will be
actually even greater for restaurants to
deliver on that promise
um but at the same time i think people
have learned to
cook at home or even set up a nice
dinner at home and i think
a few restaurants have done this quite
well over the circuit breaker where
they've
sent sets and a whole experience to the
home so i think that's that's really
another opportunity for restaurants
where you know they could be full
for for dinner uh but at the same time
they have a bad kitchen delivering
beautiful sets like audex did and a few
other restaurants
um where you can replicate that that
restaurant experience at home
um i think there will be a lot of
opportunities
at least for us to create new offline
and online sales channels so what i mean
by that
is and and as you've seen with sales
stock market
we really need to be much better at
engaging customers within a store and
then shifting them online so to give you
an example
if you love our banana cake in the store
you would have a qr code
uh in front of it that you could scan
and that directly launches you
into the checkout page for salesforce
market with one click
you've ordered your whole loaf of banana
cake
for the weekend delivered that night so
that's really the
the use of space now i think will be
very different moving forward i think we
need to continue
optimizing every square foot uh and
really thinking about how we
constantly move people online offline
and i mean you hear the o2o you know
strategy from a lot of companies but i
think
um covert has really cemented that and
made it very real for us
um the store layouts are also going to
fundamentally change i think we we've
continued adapting
our store layouts over the years but um
moving forward i think you know the
everyone's online business will grow i
think there's going to be a convergence
of
your you know in-store customers and
your delivery riders um
virtual brands a lot of people have
launched from existing kitchens that
means obviously a different back of the
house set up as well
uh contactless experience i think that
is here to stay as well
and i think the safe distancing measures
also have
have been very interesting to observe so
um we operate those three outfits in
hong kong and hong kong actually bounced
back
very quickly so we had a very sharp
decline in
in february but towards the end of march
early april
um it actually felt like business
business as usual
but what we did observe is a lot more
people shifting to
online pickup and we are used to
crowds and and long queues for lunch uh
what happened was that a lot of people
would then
uh stay away from that and and and move
online so
i think you know the crowds or
just busy spaces i think some people do
get a little bit uncomfortable
with that still uh and that might
actually again cement itself
uh over the next few years if this
becomes a new normal and everyone gets
used to this new way of life
uh unifying the online and physical
store funds so i think the
the challenge again for a lot of f b
operators will be that
even if they um enhance the design
experience
in store i think the expectations from
customer on what you deliver online is
now
as high as what you deliver as a
physical experience
so i think you know we've invested a lot
in our own technology and i think
the the customers expectations
in terms of us being like a delivery
or food panda i think is is also
increasing so
so we know we will never be able to
compete with them
on that side but i think there are few
touch points that are critical
uh from an online experience standpoint
and we really need to nail those those
are really
elements that we're very very focused on
now to make sure that
um we can shift some of the customers
over to our side and that again if we've
got a o2o strategy that it just feels
absolutely seamless and lastly
obviously covid will have impacted a lot
of restaurants um
very badly uh this year and i think uh
you know if if even if restaurants were
able to break even from a
uh ebitda level um they will have not
been able to cover their depreciation so
i think
restaurants will definitely be very
frugal and
stay away from any large capex
investments so i think from you know a
design perspective again i think you
know looking at low
cost materials thinking outside the box
and how we can
revamp spaces i think will be critical
over the next few years because again i
think that we're
quite far away from really being back to
normal
and i think for even for us we are we
had plans to renovate and
you know to do a whole new design i
think those will be put on hold for now
and i think we're going to be investing
more actually on the online experience
and trying to just maintain what we have
in the stores
um so that brings me to the end of my
presentations obviously we
have some questions and answers so happy
to go through those
hey adrian um yes would you like to take
one of the questions from one of them
a quick one um we have one question from
pat chong hi adrian you've shared the
outcomes of design thinking but could
you share how you went through the dt
process and with any particular
methodology you follow
um so i think when we worked with ongnom
six years ago yes i think there was a
you know we really went through
um interviewing our customers
you know working with our team um
really uh we went through a three or
four month just discovery process
and i think that was fundamental to
really
laying a base for us uh moving forward i
think it definitely shifted our mindset
uh and and i think design thinking has
just become part of the organization now
uh i think it a big part of it is also i
guess the culture that we have
internally so
we you know we constantly challenge
ourselves to to think
further and that we have a very young
team
um that is very exposed to i guess what
is happening also
outside of singapore so we were very
aware of trends and
uh lastly i would say we're just always
in touch with customers you know so from
from you know we
we never um reply to a feedback
past 24 hours we we we are constantly
with our
eyes and ears open to um to what our
customers are saying so
i think that also um keeps us connected
keeps us
updated um and i think it really is
about sort of creating that culture
internally to
make sure that we are just constantly
innovating
thanks adrian i think um let's keep the
questions coming in we'll move on to our
next speakers
uh steen would you like to take over now
yes good morning everyone uh i hope that
everyone can
come see and hear me thank you to design
singapore for letting me
talk about one of my favorite subjects
which is design
uh as michelle said in the the opening i
ran four fingers from
2013 to 2018 i saw the business through
a quite big
growth phase but this presentation of
what i'm sharing with you today is less
about four fingers specifically
and more about me trying to share some
of the learnings and principles that i
have picked up in my
in my year in fab that i tried to apply
to four fingers four fingers is a very
visible example of that
but i really want to share with you some
of the principles and processes that
will underline
what you see with four fingers so with
that let me share my screen
so i'll talk to you about what i think
is is a good way of of developing
a brand experience and i'll talk about
that
from the point of view of how i've spent
my last uh
30 years working with big brands and
also as an entrepreneur
and those of you who are thinking
whether i started working when i was
three years old i'm actually not as
young as i hopefully look
but i have spent a lot of time three
decades working with some some big
brands
starting with disney working with disney
consumer products but also being very
involved with the theme parks
at the movies moving on to mcdonald's
uh later on with burger king um i ran
baskin robbins copying tea leave
in indonesia i launched costa coffee in
singapore
and at the moment i just went through
that position of domino's pizza
in the philippines um underlying all
this is is really having a chance to
work with some great people so later in
the presentation i'll share with you
some of the people that have inspired me
in in my thinking and how i have taken
their principles and applied it to to
this i'm thinking
now i mentioned also that i have some
experience as an entrepreneur
particularly two so starting with lazy
gourmet
which was a partnership that i formed
with lisa me
back in 2007. some people might ask why
would i
move from fast food burger king to liza
me
and it was a bit of an odd constellation
but actually a very fruitful
partnership we had because there was a
lot of osmosis between lizard me and
myself
me thinking in terms of things like uni
economics scalability
listen me think in terms of quality and
experience and so on so i picked up many
things in this i mean
we developed lazy gourmet which was a
brand of frozen
package gourmet foods soups pasta sauces
and stews
that people could prepare at home
we launched successfully in a number of
supermarkets throughout singapore
jason's marketplace fair price finest
meiji and so on and the products were
selling really really well
but in the end we closed it um
because we have spent a lot of time on
what consumers saw
the packaging the food the designs the
website and so on and we had completely
ignored largely the business model and
economics behind it
so while consumers really liked our
products and and bought them often and
frequently
we were not making any money because we
had set our own standards very very high
so as we scaled up the business we did
not make any more money so we decided to
close it eventually
in 2009 partly because we were
ahead of the home delivery wave which
really took off like
five six years ago my second
experience as an entrepreneur really was
taking over four fingers in 2013 when it
was just
one store great brand great experience
great design all designed by a singapore
agency called
asylum which i thought did a terrific
job so my job was not so much to
really create the brand but rather
figure out why it worked so well
both for what consumers saw but also
what you saw as the operator
and as the investor where four fingers
are doing
very strong sales four fingers has very
high called space efficiency
uh very high unit economics which means
that customers are happy and the
investors are also happy
and that's the first lesson i really
want to share with you that i find that
the creative
design process must go hand in hand
with financial discipline it's very
important that you all the time
apply that filter or checkpoint that
says this is really nice but can we make
money and is it something that is
scalable so in the case of of lazy
gourmet
not really in the case of four fingers
it worked out very nicely so this is the
first lesson i want you
to take as a as a takeaway now i talk a
lot about brands and most of my career
has been
spent working with very big consumer
brands and what i find is useful is to
distinguish between
branding and brand building these terms
are often
mixed up in my view branding is just
really
about attaching your name or logo to
something a bottle
or packaging or whatever it may be
whereas
brand building is the process of
creating designing and building specific
associations
in relation to a product or service now
these situations
only exist inside consumers these are
not something you can you can give to
them
it's something that's a build up over
time if you
as a brand operator are consistent with
your brand experience
so we can ask ourselves what do we need
to build a brand
and my experience from mcdonald's was
that mcdonald's
was found to be one of the largest
brands in the world
but we realized when i was working there
that no one had brand
on their name card no one had the name
brand as part of their job function
so we said how can we become one of the
world's largest brands
if known specifically in charge of brand
and what we realized was that we had
basically over decades
been maniacally focused with consistency
around standards that we had set
ourselves so over time
people came to rely on mcdonald's for
very particular experience
so in my mind everything you need to do
to build a brand is to set your own
standards
and be consistent with these over time
every store
of the customer and your brand and the
brand experience
will automatically come from that
now why are brands then important well
customers and consumers like value they
like to get as much as they can
for as little as possible so i find this
equation where we say
brand experience over price is the value
you provide to your customers
so you can say either you cut prices and
therefore the value goes up
or you can grow the brand experience and
therefore the value will go up and my
talk of course is about really about the
brand experience design
um that we can we can hopefully all
learn something from
so what we know about brands are that
they do take time and they do require
resources
people and money to be built but they
also provide momentum
in times of trouble whether you have a
temporary crisis it may be food
poisoning or whether you are seeing
something like what we expected right
now
kobe 19 brands haven't mentioned that
carry you
through these so it makes sense for us
to invest in building brands
secondly brands are a great way to
capture and defend
sales markets here and profit because
once you have occupied a space
with consumers once you have taken the
time and resources to enter
consumers minds and create these
associations you sit there
and other market entrants will have a
struggle to come in and compete with you
perfect example is that that four
figures success
created a lot of market entrance but
most of them failed because they were
really much more in the area of
executing providing people some chicken
rather than creating a brand experience
and then lastly brands
create economic value and i will show an
example of what i mean with that
so let's take a cup of coffee as an
example
if you go out and you buy some beans you
need about 10 grams of beans to make a
cup of coffee
that is a commodity if you take
ground beans from a pack then you are
using a product
if you go to the kopitian and you buy a
cup of coffee
you're getting a service and if you go
to starbucks
you are getting a brand experience
now the amount of coffee needed for
these four examples
is the same but if you look at what
happens on how much money people spend
if you buy copper beans as a commodity
you spend a few cents
you spend a bit more once it becomes a
product
when it's a service competition 1.50
but if you go to starbucks you spend a
lot more than that
but the input costs are more or less the
same the cost of the coffee beans
is more or less the same in all these
examples but by building a brand
experience
starbucks create immense value around
those coffee beans
now i will introduce the term customer
journey which to me
really is sort of what happens when
someone sees your brand for the first
time
and when will they eventually after
having tried you decide whether to come
back
or not um i used to go to chicago quite
a lot when i work with mcdonald's
and there is a fantastic nike shop um
on michigan avenue called nike town it's
a three-story building
which uses sights and sound music
technology all sorts of effects to
create a three-dimensional experience
for its customers
staff in particular are fantastic there
and that store
attracts more visitors than all the
museums
in chicago combined so again talk about
the pool you can create with a strong
brand experience
i mentioned disney as a brand that i
encountered earlier on in my career
we always talk about the disney magic
but what it really boils down to is the
fact that disney
intentionally over manages certain parts
of the customer journey that other
brands overlooked
some of you may have visited disneyland
or disney world
i attended a training session with
disneyland
a couple years ago and they shared that
nothing is left of
circumstance or coincidence when you
visit one of their parks
there are about 1483
unique touch points or magical moments
where you
interact with the brand either
statically you might be a sign
or with the staff and each of these
touch points are included
in one or more job descriptions um in
the theme park of which that by the way
are 2 000 about 2 000 job descriptions
but every one of these
has clear kpis and quality assurance
so really by by being very focused on
intentionally over managing
these touch points disney is creating
this magic for the last 100 years
so you will see the box at the bottom
left it talks about what are the brand
pillars
for disney in this case it is firstly
safety is critically important secondly
that there should be some efficiency no
one likes to sit in a queue for
a long time treating customers or
visitors with courtesy is important
and lasting element of showmanship is
important to disney
so what disney says is all about touch
points can be split into people
places where they work and things that
they do so if you start with disney
you will get a matrix that looks like
this and you will see which of the touch
points are you accountable for
in the job that you do and where you
stand and what you do and i think this
is a brilliant example of how can you
take something that is very fussy
and boil it down to something that is
very easy to manage easy to communicate
easy to measure
so i'm from scandinavia and
there is a joint venture between denmark
norway and sweden
to operate an airline called sas it was
launched in the
50s and and sort of never really came
out of the oil crisis in 1970s
and was struggling with bankruptcy for
many years
at some point they said let's try
something new they had a change on
executive coming in to run the business
but but
they don't really manage to turn around
so they approached a guy called jan
carlson
and please write this down john colson
wrote a book about this called moments
of truth you
must absolutely read it jan carlsen
was not an airline executive he came
from a travel agency
and he said i don't know how to run an
airline and the board said well that's
why we want you because you can provide
a fresh perspective
so he took the job and the first thing
he did was to round up all the staff
from the head office
in a big aircraft hangar he walked up
one of these jet ways to use in the old
days to get on planes
and he said hi i'm jan carlson i'm your
new ceo
i don't know anything about running an
airline but i know that you do
so i look forward to hearing from you so
his message was loud and clear
all these changes that can can bring
about positive impact
doesn't always come from top management
it can come from
people who are facing customers who are
on the floor
later on as i said famously he said that
sas
moves about 10 million people a year
they are on average in touch with five
employees
and every interaction lasts about 15
seconds so
their brand is created 50 million times
a year
in 15 second brackets and these moments
of truth
is when sas can prove to its customers
that sas
is the best alternative i highly
recommend you reading this book it's not
very
very long but it provides you with two
great principles
one of which i'm sharing with you today
about how to manage the moments of truth
now brand experience and customer
journey
let me introduce you to the concept of
brand inertia brand inertia is how
likely you as a consumer are
to repeat a purchase from a brand
so let's imagine now shake shack shake
shack launched in singapore
quite recently and each one of you will
have heard
about shake shack for the very first
time and based on that you will have
decided
whether you want to try it or where
there's nothing for you if you say you
will give it a chance
you will go through a customer journey
that will have a number of touch points
and at the end of the first exposure you
will decide you want to do that again
or you will never come back when we talk
about brand inertia
we're talking about increasing the
chance of you saying
i would definitely go back and avoiding
people saying never again
so how does this happen well let's think
about this journey as happening at
different levels so
think about media as one area where
brands can reach consumers
you think about outlets which is where
you build the stores how they're
configured
you think about the kind of products
that you're serving
in what environment and think about the
staff so either we can leave up to
chance
how all these things happen or we can
take every single point along the red
line and say
how do we intentionally create and over
manage this so we maximize
the chance people at the end say great i
would do that again
so i've used examples here media outlet
product and staff
but for each of your businesses you can
define what are the different levels
that you think are the leapers that you
have to work with and each of these will
have
more granularity so for instance outlet
can be designed lighting
music seating and so on product can be
you know
the value you provide the choice variety
staff can be the interaction so on but
what i want to show is that we cannot
leave these things up to chance
because if you do not intentionally and
with great deliberation
create the customer journey it will
create itself
and that may not be what you want as the
brandon
okay so what i'll do now is i'll try to
sort of
calculate what i've shared with you into
some examples
from four fingers really started by
saying in retail and fmb
what are the tools or the labels we can
use
to design a unique brand experience for
our brand
so that can be things like interior
design where you build the store
the kind of food you serve how much you
charge how the seasoning is arranged and
so
you can see a long long list of things
that are not always
deliberately and intentionally used by
the brand owners
and one of the things i'd like to pause
on is on the aspect of technology
because i find technology
is usually seen as a way to gain
efficiency
and save money and so on and i think
that's all good and very well
but i believe technology much in line
with what daniel
so aiden showed earlier is it's really
all about using that to create
a unique customer journey how do you
interact with customers how do you
customize
your offer to them based on what you
know about them
how do you create a seamless uh
custom experience that will at the end
of the day increase the value
for customers so moving on to
to four fingers um as i mentioned four
fingers were started in 2009 it was one
store
when i came in it was already very well
configured but the business was kind of
held back in its growth
through some structural issues in
relation to shareholders funding and so
on so my job was to say
rather than create the brand which i i
can't say that i did
it is to protect and refine all the
things that made the brand work so well
so starting with what do we get involved
in in terms of the courses
as a brand how are consumers exposed to
four fingers
some of you may remember the rigor
olympics back in the day when people
could still
congregate and and and be together in
big spaces
um we sent a national role aisha
who had the big dream of going to the
olympics and row for singapore
she was starting to get funding um from
the sports council
and in the end i've known aj for many
years because i'm also a row i said look
four fingers will take care of this for
you so we put on a stipend
that allowed her to train we supported
her journey
to to rio and even though she didn't
come back as a winner
she was in our minds a winner because
she represented singapore in the
olympics to me this is the highest
possible honor you can achieve
to represent your country in olympics
now why would that be something for four
fingers
it was because as a brand and as a
business we also had big dreams
big aspirations we had determination to
really
move things and achieve something that
was great so we said this is
a very nice way for us to start
later on we said well let's get involved
with with other people that are known
in singapore but a bit more rebellious
because the four things brand dna
was also about being disruptive and a
bit rebellious
so sam low also known as sticker lady
was
famous for infamous few years ago
because she walked around and put
stickers
on on road signs and stop signals in
singapore
and was actually arrested and thrown to
jail for vandalism
she didn't stay in jail for long she
came out with a slap in the wrist but we
thought wow here is a real rebel here's
someone who is challenging the
establishment someone who is a small
underdog up against the good liars sam
is very involved in social courses and
we say we like that very very much
so we asked her to decorate some of our
stores again because as a brand
it's about more than just providing some
seating and she's done some wonderful
artwork for us
in our stores and she continues to be
very involved in social courses we like
that very much
but then we say well since music as i'll
talk about later is an important part of
the fourth fingers brand experience
let's take music outside the store so
people will see us outside the stores
and we arranged the first um ever open
air concert in singapore where local
bands and local djs
got on stage we rented ford canning and
provided a free concert
for anyone who wants to come we couldn't
sell four fingers food there and then
it didn't really matter because we were
not doing this
for make a profit we did it because as a
brand it was an amazing and awesome
thing to do
there were other vendors there and parts
of their proceeds went to charity so it
was a very very nice thing that
of course did cost some money but it
garnered big big big
media value for us in terms of the
exposure that we got
okay moving on to store design which is
sort of the very tangible part of the
of the store experience design
if you think about four fingers you
probably think about red
white gray black and white
with some timber so this is a unique
design language
of vocabulary that i that i said let's
stick to this
because i want all the stores to be
recognizable
and distinct but also unique i i don't
like uniformity but what i like is that
the stores all look not like twins but
like crosses
so we developed a design language that
was quite consistent in the use of
colors and textures
red gray white black but also used
timber to kind of soften the overall
impact
of the stores and as we built the stores
we made sure that we tried to make them
um relevant for our customers so in the
bottom left corner you can see a
community wall where one can write a
greeting or a poll whatever you'd like
to add
on the top right corner you will see how
we painted
um our logo i wanted to look like
someone snuck in the middle of night i
painted it with a big brush pretty
quickly because again as a brand we were
non-conformed so i'll take you through a
few slides that shows you
the design of the stores and here i
really want to touch
very importantly on space efficiency so
we all know
that rent is very expensive in singapore
so maximizing
the area we can use for customers is
critically important if you think about
the counter
you see that it's moved all the way up
to the lease line so conventionally the
counter will always sit you know five
ten meters back
people walk up but all that that space
is wasted we move the counter all the
way up to the front because it uses
space better
and we can serve customers right as they
pass us
secondly you will see that the seating
arrangements inside the stores
is quite close quite communal so we can
pack a lot of seats into a small space
which is good for the number of
customers you can have in the store at
any given time
overall to me the store should should
really have
no sign of four fingers inside the
stores other than if we consider it to
be as an ornament but you will see that
the four icons the four the hand the
korean sign and the chicken
is something we used as an icon and as
an ornamental store design
uh moving inside the store that the tall
tables
actually were not very often in use
because people in asia like to say that
lower tables
but we use it because it signals
something a bit more casual to our
customers
we like very much the use of lighting
not as
illumination but as decoration so so
customers
when they glance inside the store can
see these guys are open right
um so for me lighting is very often
underutilized to create
ambience to emphasize colors and
textures the gray cement screen wall you
see there
was was actually inspired by by me
cycling through a tunnel
in denmark and i just like this very raw
finish of
of the walls i like the texture brings
and you will see the use of timber also
is there to really soften the hardness
of the white and the gray tiles
not many signs have four fingers inside
the stores other than these icons which
we consider to be
iconic if i can say that for our brand
so it's there for more decoration than
actually advertisement
now talk about packaging which is
another lever that we have to build the
brand
uh four fingers decided to actually
increase
the cost of packaging because it allowed
us to buy
packaging that was more environmentally
friendly
and more recyclable in singapore we
still don't have a lot of recyclability
because
most of our trash goes into one shoot
and off to
either landfill or waste incineration
but as a brand we said
we would take a step in the right
direction we would actually have more
cost
because we believe that is an investment
in building the brand perceptions
we also see that on the top right we
have our mess tin
which is iconic for four fingers but
also very good because it produces
packaging because all you need is just a
simple piece of max paper
now my favorite subject which is stuff
and uniforms and i'll share a little
anecdote with you
i joined mcdonald's many many years ago
as a marketing manager
and i was told but first you report to
the store you worked there for two weeks
to understand what's going on
and i was given at that time a hideous
uniform
that i did not feel well in i did not
like wearing it as i was standing and
serving customers there
so i said if i one day can design
uniforms for a brand
i want uniforms that people will want to
wear to and from work
and i'm very happy to to share that our
staff would actually
be stopped um by customers in public
transport and say oh you work for four
fingers gonna take a selfie and so on
because
they like the uniforms they like their
brand but staff is really so much more
um than just handling transactions right
i think
technology allows you to replace some of
these
menial tasks of handling transactions
and deploy staff
to tasks that are much more about
interacting with customers about making
sure customers are happy making sure
that customers expectations
are exceeded and in this journey of of
designing
our brand experience coming back to that
long red line
we worked with an agency quite a call id
action
who insisted on talking to my staff
about how to create all these brand
moments and touch points and i was
actually quite skeptical and said
i don't really think they're used to
this kind of discussion but have a
question
and i was very very pleased to be proven
wrong because
the moment that we opened up for our
staff to share
ideas this amazing wealthiness of we can
do this we can do that
bubble dog so first of all i got really
good ideas that we can document
but secondly as we rolled out our brand
promise and our brand journey
half the job of communicating it was
already done because the staff
recognized their own ideas
inside that work and it's an important
point that i wanted to share
coming from young carlson talking to the
staff in the aircraft flank and says i
don't know
how to run an airline but i know you do
we said to our staff
you are the ones facing our customers so
please share with us all your great
ideas
i would also spend a lot of time dealing
with the staff either in the stores or
do
town halls where i think the ceo of a
company sets the tone and he leads by
example
you need to spend time with your staff
to show that you share the same value
that you expect them to communicate with
your customers
and the last bit i want to share is that
i i find too often that music is
something where
a restaurant just you know just turn on
the radio on some cheese cheesy
loudspeakers
i find music and acoustics critically
important to creating a big band
experience
so we would spend quite a lot of money
on the sound systems
in our stores and we had a playlist
on on spotify which had music
that had been curated to really
communicate the brand's energy
and its pulse and we played it in the
stores over good speakers
and a little bit loud because we thought
should be a very prominent part of the
four fingers experience
so i hope i've given you some examples
of how we intentionally
manage these aspects of the customer
journey and importantly how we used our
staff
who are really our brand ambassadors to
communicate many of these
so in in summary to make every brand
experience unique you first decide what
is your brand's dna
if you haven't done that you really have
no destination
for arriving at you also need to
understand
not the customer social demographics but
understand your customer psychographics
what mindset
are you trying to appeal to what kind of
customer values and principle are you
connecting with especially this day and
age
where consumers are feeling less and
less
customers feeling more and more inclined
to find brands that are authentic and
real rather than big
corporate brands understanding what are
you trying to connect with
at that emotional level is important and
then you go about identifying your
brand's touch points
at the multiple remember the slide i
showed you with the red line the layers
underneath
think about that and say what should be
the very first time people hear about
our brand
and what are all the touch points along
the way where we can we can
we can please them and thrill them and
see their expectations
usual staff you'll be surprised how many
good ideas are coming up
and then when you have all this make
sure you set standards so you can
measure
these things for instance service time
is critically important
we should always achieve a hit rate of
eighty percent of three minutes or
whatever may be your kpi
document these and make sure that you
have follow up on it
internal marketing is critically
important because without that your
staff
might not really be switched on and
engaged in what you're trying to achieve
so the internal marketing is very very
important
so the external marketing can really
prove that
training and retraining is very
important and lastly
making sure that you follow up that you
measure and you correct along the way
in a nutshell running an fmb restaurant
in my view
is about doing two things only but doing
them really well
it's about figuring out what is that
customer journey
what is one customer experience and then
you document that well and you scale it
up
hundreds of times per day per restaurant
that's the micro level
at the macro level it's about figuring
out how you configure a store
in the best possible location with the
best possible space efficiency with the
best possible design
so that the economic realities behind
running your business
are also maximized so it's the micro and
the macro coming together
that to me is what brand design is
really all about
and with that i think i have expanded my
time and i
thank you for your attention
thanks dean um i think we'll just
quickly take one question
from an attendee so she said hi steen
you have shared about
the disney magic which is created by
over managing
do you have any insights on how they
structured that magic team and how large
the team is so we just take this
question and then we'll move on to the
next segment but
we'll take more questions during the q a
and panel discussion
good excellent question so what what
disney does is
disney really focuses on its staff
before its customers
and it doesn't work out at all about its
shareholders what the thinking is to say
if our staff is really happy really
proud
and really committed to work with us
then we don't need to worry much about
the customers because our
staff will do that for us and if
customers are happy and please then our
shareholders will be happy because
customers will come back more often and
spend more money so disney puts a lot of
emphasis
on on onboarding people when you get
your official name tag with disney
that's a big deal
for disney that is a bit like your birth
certificate you are now part of the team
so i think what what we can learn as
operators is to say never underestimate
the importance of of really
making sure that people who are the
front liners
are committed and are on board and
understand the mission
okay i hope that answered your question
thank you steen
okay we'll now move on to the segment on
the schemes for smes
i also hope everyone have enjoyed that
very insightful sharing and inspiring
share from
steen and as well as adrian both these
companies have transformed their
businesses using this approach
that is actually the design thinking
methodology which i'll explain briefly
in a bit
before i get to before i get into that
uh
i'd just like to share a short
introduction on the council
so design singapore is the national
agency for design in singapore we
champion
um the classical design disciplines like
graphic
architecture as well as fashion so we
have emerging design disciplines coming
off as well
such as experience design and service
design
so and all the other sort of design
thinking related methodologies that
help to drive innovation for companies
basically
our ultimate vision um is to help
singapore become
an innovation driven economy and a
livable city by design by 2025.
so just uh to show them one the the
definition of design thinking
design thinking is not just about design
for visuals
or design for a shop front it's about
the balancing act of putting people
business and technology together but
always starting with
what your users find desirable or what
they need
so sometimes in i think an example of uh
steen's case right
your users are also your employees you
know your frontliners
and that's essential so uh steen also
talk about you know business economics
users needs and then supporting that
with technology as well as
business viability when you're able to
achieve this sweet spot is when
innovation can take place and when
innovation can happen
so underpinning design thinking is this
very fundamental five-step
process starting with empathizing with
your users needs
so you heard from uh sellerstop as well
as from steen that
how they go about gathering feedback and
insights is
when you talk to their customers or when
their customers gives them the feedback
and then you go to the next step to
define the problem and scoping it down
followed by an ideation phase where you
brainstorm on potential ideas
and then rapidly testing it in other
words to prototype
and then uh bring testing those ideas
again and again so this
iterative process is what really
underpins the design thinking
uh methodology and
in a nutshell design thinking can be
used to
help ultimately shape and improve
customer experience as you've heard
earlier as well
how to pivot your businesses into
adjacent markets
improve and sharpen brand positioning
even helping you to go digital
and building brand keep building
capabilities
through that process you get to have a
deeper understanding of your users needs
their behaviors they risk the innovation
process and then safe cause in the
meantime because you rapidly prototype
and expedite the whole development
process so you heard from adrian i think
he
managed to launch an entire website
within a week because
they have prototyping mechanisms in
place to able to launch and they risk
uh you know their sort of process and
quickly
wrote things out so if you are entirely
new to this concept
no ways at all we hope today's session
is a primer that will help
inspire you to find out more about
design thinking in fact as the council
we have recently rolled out two schemes
in collaboration with enterprise
singapore
esg for short for companies who wish to
start using design to transform their
businesses
companies can receive up to 80 subsidies
so the first one
it's on the use of user journey mapping
for businesses as the name suggests
this is similar to what steen mentioned
in terms of mapping out touch points
when
your customer interacts with your brand
that's one
under that first option right oh sorry
the first scheme user journey mapping
there's three options
and then we have the second one which is
called frame and scope
if you are inspired by the approach that
are shared by these two speakers
you'll be definitely wanting to embark
on these two schemes so the frame and
scope one is a slightly more uh
expanded upon version i'll explain a bit
later the first one
i'd like to talk about is the user
journey mapping scheme
uh this gear gives the companies you
know an um
an actual customer journey map as in
deliverable i'll show you how that looks
like in a bit
this map allows you to evaluate the
entire process of how your users are
interacting with your brand
the positive the negative experience as
well as all the good and bad touch
points
so you might be you know thinking to
yourself how can my company
use this what problems can i use it for
right
so these are some of the examples of
problem statements that we've been
helping some other companies with
how might we improve the digital
learning experience of a cooking academy
for example
how do we want to improve the whole
student registration process and then
is there a way for my business to
improve the in-store experience
so we can't name the companies but these
are some of the
live problem statements that our
consultants are
panel of consultants are helping the
companies on
okay now i'll show you an example of
what the user journey mapping looks like
basically um as you have heard from the
earlier speakers it is
sort of like a journey map and its most
basic form it compiles
a series of user goals and actions into
a timeline
this timeline is then fleshed out with
users thoughts
and emotions in order to create a
narrative around it
and then this narrative is condensed
into this visualization
which helps to communicate insights
informing the whole design process
okay so i'll show you another more
fleshed out version very relevant to the
to the today's discussion on food
ordering right
so this is um this is an example of one
uh someone going about to order food you
know where the high points the low
points
you know how she feels stressed by you
know working a very busy schedule and
then she starts
looking for place to relax during lunch
time so you get to see
where are the places that you can
actually impact
and start reaching out to your customers
it's a very simple concept but when you
actually flash it out
the insights are more than what you can
expect
so back to uh the scheme this is
expanding on the three options under
your user journey mapping
um there will be three different
variations that we're offering to
companies
in each of these options you get to work
with
you have the choice to work with your
preferred design consultants basically
three options vary in the extent
of which you want to go how how deep you
want to do
uh go go with the project as well as
your budget
in the first option it is uh suitable
for customer facing companies who want a
quick understanding of their current
customer journey so uh as you have seen
just now
the customer journey map is going to be
that deliverable based on one persona
and in option two it will be a more
slightly more extensive
version that will cover up to three to
four personas so these are
suitable for businesses who are trying
to reach out to potential new customer
segments
for your products or services and in
option three
apart from surveying your external
stakeholders which is your customers
this option also takes you through how
you you know how your internal back-end
operations
as well as your stuff actions affect the
external customers so it's
a whole service design blueprint front
end and back-end combined
okay in the second scheme which is the
design for business frame and scope
uh this is for companies with with a
larger appetite
so using a similar but more extensive
process it will help companies
identify and prioritize key areas of
transformation and then
outlining a strategic roadmap as a final
deliverable so far we have six companies
who have onboarded this scheme with us
of which three of them have already
completed the initial phase
here are some examples of their project
objectives
you know how do you engage millennials
and create that
new experience beyond selling products
how do you develop an experienced
strategy to
you know target the affluent group of
customers
and then um can we curate umbrella of
brands for
turnkey offerings that you know offer
new odo offline to online service and
experiences so these are just some of
the
um the problem statements that companies
can work on with this scheme
you can immediately see already from you
know the difference between the type of
ask
based on these statements from the first
one and the second one
so this frame and scope is a deep
exploration
and understanding of possible new
business opportunities on areas of
transformation
uh it's a slightly longer program that
was spent between six to eight
weeks there are two key phases to keep
in mind
the first phase is funded by the council
the design console and the letter by
uh enterprise singapore so by the end of
phase one you'll be getting that high
level strategy
roadmap outlining certain
recommendations and then with that
document
the consultants that you choose to work
with will help you draft
the grant proposal which you then can
use instead to get more funding from esg
if
your grand proposal is approved so
that's
in a nutshell that's all the schemes i
have to share with you
i know that's a lot to digest but no
worries if you cannot remember
most of the schemes just know that know
the details of the scheme just know that
there's two
essentially two schemes that you can
potentially tap on just help me indicate
your interest
at the end of the session for us to fill
you in with more details so this one
will
just indicate in the survey form that
you be able to scan later on
so i'd like to pass the time now over to
kai singh we'll be helping to moderate
the panel discussions
thank you hi
thanks everybody thanks michelle adrian
and steen for sharing
um and thanks to all of you um it's
really amazing to see like
in a single morning we've got more than
100 people here
and there's a mix of uh people working
in the fmb
uh other organizations there's also
designers amongst us
and design firms so hopefully we'll be
able to have a discussion that's
that you know we can ask questions that
are both valuable
uh for these uh fmb uh companies
as well as the design firms and partners
um we'll answer some there are some
specific questions that we'll answer a
little bit later as well
uh if you have time to gather and um
yeah i just want to appreciate the
hearing from steen and adrian uh there's
a lot around the
the the connection between the business
strategy and design
that you all both have shared there's
this thing around playing with physical
and digital and how those two have to
interface really well
other things about brand and co-creation
with a big group
um i guess i want to start off with
linking it back to
michelle's sharing and you
you're now on the other side where
you've done a little bit of customer
journey mapping you've done a bit of
design thinking processes
how useful do you think would these two
schemes be for companies and
you know what what are the positives
that you think people can get out of
that
um yeah steve would you like to
start us off with that yeah i think what
what the starting point for this should
be
not to do just because there's a grant i
i mean i've seen many companies
do programs because there's a ground
right i think it starts by
understanding what are the business
opportunities
that you are facing as a company
and what are the challenges on the way
to realizing these opportunities
um so i think depending on what the
specific need is
i think i think both grants actually are
very relevant and and
as i mentioned uh when we spoke
yesterday i've been in singapore for
more than 20 years and i think that we
as
smes are exceptionally fortunate in
singapore to have
a public sector that is so much in tune
with the private sector
and provides grants that are there for
companies that are willing to take risk
right so four things has done a lot of
innovation and seen a lot of general
report
support from from enterprise singapore
but the projects would have been done
anyway i think that's my key point right
you should do these things because you
see a business need and the fact that
there
is a grant that will fit that it's just
an upside but you shouldn't do it just
because there's a ground
great and i think just to add as well um
the customer landscape is changing so
rapidly right now that even for us i
mean we
you know we do this internally but we
are
always working with different partners
on mapping this out we're actually in
the midst of doing this
um to to look more specifically at our
online
customer behavior and what we need to
adapt there um so i think
it is just an ongoing process so i think
this is a simple way for a lot of
companies to just
jump on board um understand the design
thinking process and then hopefully
that's you know a mindset they can keep
for the longer term uh and i think also
you know we we talked maybe about you
know a lot of the projects that we've
uh embarked on and i think you know with
steen obviously when you you know build
a bearing from scratch like that
there's so many elements to consider but
i don't think it necessarily always
needs to cost that much i think
um you know we we come across
a lot of third-party platforms different
solutions that you can just get off the
shelf
uh that you can just plug into your
business and and this is all
hopefully also what the consultants you
know would would help offer is that you
know you you can
get up to speed also very quickly um
without having to
you know run a huge budget
thank you adrian um yeah and on this uh
note around
consultants and getting a partner to
support uh i'm curious for
for some of the smes and businesses that
want to go on this journey
and their first starting point what
would your
criteria be for selecting a design
partner so like
for adrian if you work with and on a
while back uh we've seen
with with asylum my idea uh just could
you talk us through
you know what was the thinking process
of selecting such a partner that's
just right for you so i think it's a mix
between sort of
using standard templates and guiding us
through maybe something that is
a little bit more cookie cutter and that
obviously i think any company should
follow and then
outside of the box thinking i think you
know we we
as a company at least are always
at the forefront of looking at what
other international markets are doing
um and i think based on our own
life cycle and what we're going through
i think that also
sometimes needs maybe a slightly
different perspective
and i think that's where you know maybe
moving forward working with
a big international firm or
or at least a firm that has been exposed
to projects overseas sometimes also
brings a
fresh perspective so i think it then it
depends really on on what you need as a
company
i totally agree with adrian and i would
i would answer that that
you know the design is an iterative
process that can take
weeks and even a couple of months and
then what i find
is is very good is if the chemistry with
the people you work with at the
consultancy
is right so i think spending some time
on figuring out which i'm going the same
wavelength here
are you going to give me the cookie
cutter or do you really see what i'm
trying to see
i think that that's very very important
i was very lucky that we found
a very good partner in in active for
four fingers
we did go through a number because we
want the chemistry to be there
so it can be a very rewarding process
but i think
as in all partnerships it's important
that you consider it
a little bit pardon the analogy but it's
a bit like a like a racehorse with a
jockey right
they have completely different roles but
one is calling the shots
right i think you you cannot leave
leadership up to a consultant that has
to come
from the brand owner that's why i put in
my in my slide you have to determine
your brand dna first
or at least do it with the partner that
you have but that is a starting point
for for working together
right that's really interesting to uh
have this metaphor of the
jockey and the racehorse um i'm curious
for both of you what
was the what's the most important thing
you learn
when working with the design partner
racehorses
yeah that was really useful for you that
was
new to you perhaps while you're doing
your business transformation
i'll give a quick example um when we
work with our partners
their approach was a bit unorthodox
right they wanted to work with
all the frontliners and and i i said uh
they're not gonna they're not they're
not gonna
know what you're talking about they're
not used to sitting in a meeting room
right
and i was fortunate proven completely
wrong
because once these people were
able to articulate their ideas a lot of
things came up right so
i think in that process what to me was
very sobering is
that i had been sort of preaching the
approach
of jan carlson you know you have all the
ideas but i probably wasn't reliving it
right but with the help of the
consultant said okay so you told us we
can do it so we will do it
and i was proven wrong in terms of of
what we could and could not see from the
start because it was absolutely
fantastic
really really surprising right so great
like design design is institutionalizing
or systematizing the
the values that young council was
talking about
yeah so adrian do you want to add on to
that yeah i agree i think i mean
for us the the the most i guess
transformational part or
what we see is just how the team changes
you know getting them involved
in this process every time is is such a
big part of their own growth but they
bring
so many ideas and and that's you know
the
the the journey that as well is is very
exciting and i think you know
what we've also noticed is that if we
like uh steen said if we've had some
chemistry with that
partner what we end up doing is very
often we bring them back
in for smaller projects so you know when
we redid our logo
and ken had moved on and created parable
you know from ongoing
so we continued working with him
recently we created a new brand for
indonesia
um with ken smusher we did the logo with
ken
so we just know that he gets it it takes
us
five minutes just to have a conversation
on the project
and he can do something in two weeks so
i think that's also
you know for us how we look at it it
really isn't just a consultant that
comes in
and gives you a template it hopefully is
a partner in the business in some ways
right thanks thanks for sharing that um
yeah and i think we've got a couple of
questions and i'll
bring one of them in and the question is
about who should
champion design thinking it takes a big
mindset change visionary to initiate
adopted
and some of the people might be thinking
oh uh you know i
i might have to redesign a few stores at
once like should i go
big bang and just turn everything upside
down and redesign it or should i
try go small and try something small off
to the side maybe
uh what's your sense in terms of what
kind of advice do you think you can give
them
steam you wanna go first well i think
the benefit we have as smes is that we
can make decisions
pretty quickly right in my time with
burger king mcdonald's are big big
companies
and decision algorithms are just
extremely long and
and to me the benefit we have as smes is
that we can prototype really fast
as my my big uh hero kev also said if
we're not prepared to come up with
something that is wrong and to fail we
will never have something
that is original right and i think the
idea of prototyping
having an iterative process where you
launch
and tweak and if you have model it's
pilot one
use one or two outlets to pilot things
before you go big because you can
measure things right away
so i think let's not begin to think like
big companies because inherently they're
very slow
to make decisions right let's think of
small companies where
a few key people that i think the
question was who owns the process
it starts with the ceo maybe he doesn't
do all the work
but he needs to own and champion and be
behind the process 100
otherwise it will never fly uh and then
be prepared to make big decisions pilot
and iterate and reiterate along the way
yeah and also nodding yeah yeah
i totally agree and i think also you
know if if
that store gets rebuilt i think it's not
about just addressing the design
changes that need to be done now for
what you are facing but really thinking
ahead so for example for us it means
hopefully moving to a completely
cashless solution
uh in the next year uh that would be a
big step
for us because some customers will not
be happy but
we also know that that is the future for
us we know we need to move in that
direction we've
tested it with other concepts in other
markets so
i i think that's also part of the
mistakes you'll make
you might not have designed it properly
and and customers will be frustrated and
the technology doesn't work and all that
but
then it's all about continuously
prototyping with what you can and then
at some point obviously bringing on
a consultant that has hopefully that
experience and having
implemented it elsewhere
all right thank you again one question
that was specifically uh addressed to
you but i think
uh a lot of steam's perspectives a bit
later on uh adrian you talked about
um you know trying out with discounts
and that didn't
work out and that's interesting because
you initially talked about price
sensitivity
and then you thought was discounts not
working
yeah there's some curiosity about why
why do you think that is
and um you also talked about
selling stock connect rolling out within
a week normal from idea
to launch is a week like that like
really crazy really short timeline like
how do you manage what's the typical
timeline for your design
ideas getting pushed out okay so so i
think on the
discount for the last few months
we've really just been targeting um our
i guess existing customer base so our
existing customer base
luckily is not too price sensitive uh
and
i think when we did do any discount uh
we would be in a sea of one for ones and
50 percent
and it is just not something that we
believe in as a brand so we're willing
to give a little bit
to try to incentivize people um that
example i gave was just one of many
where we tried to drive more traffic to
the stores again but obviously a lot of
people were just ordering online
um so i think sometimes it's just the
messaging and
again that is part of just the a b
testing that we do constantly and and
actually um being able to do more of
this online
is fascinating i think we are really a
data driven company
we make a lot of our decisions based on
data and i think that is actually also a
very important point so
if we work with a design firm we
throw a lot of data points at them
because that that for us is what speaks
the numbers ultimately will will tell
the truth as well so i think
you know uh we continuously reiterate
based on what we see and what traction
we get
and i think on saladstop connect um
people have all felt it was a great idea
but we've not
seen the adoption just yet so we've seen
it i mean obviously a few people have
tried it
but being able to kind of convince them
to then use it is
is a different story so now again uh
we're gonna have to
to crack that and um we built something
very quickly
we're irritating we're getting a few
people to test it giving us their
feedback
constantly changing at the same with the
salad stock marketplace
we're learning a lot finding our niche
and then you know tweaking things as we
go along
right yeah i've seen how about you like
what was the typical timeline for you
previously fought fingers well i will
just hook on on the question of of
discounting
because discounting to me is essentially
a function of having
an oversupply and on demand so i think
as you manage your business how many
stores you build how often and how big
it's critically important to make sure
that your brand demand is always ahead
of
of your brand supply if you are less
available that people want you
you don't have to discount stores will
fill up themselves and what i like about
what what
was mentioned by adrian is the
definitive technology because
it can make it easier for customers to
go through an order
but it also means that they spend more
money right i have not spoken to anyone
who does ekios and so on
that doesn't say average check goes up
by 15 to 20
just because relying on on staff to
trade customers up
is is a process that may not work but if
you're following an algorithm where you
show people a nice photo and click here
to add and so on
you will see that your that your sales
automatically
go up and you can reallocate those staff
from cashiering to other
nicer more value-adding tasks inside the
store
now specific time i can't tell you yes
or no but
i my philosophy as a ceo was always to
empower my people make sure that they
knew what were expected but also they
had the decisions
uh how to make decisions and so on i
always think it's better to
as i say act first and defend later i
don't mind people making mistakes
if it is an interest of doing something
sooner rather than later as long as we
avoid repeating mistakes because if we
repeat mistakes they're not mistakes
their
choice right
and now unto that point i think eric
wong was asking
a question about the ceo needing to do
this
and learning from mistakes and he asked
in an era where people are impatient
and maybe do not feel compelled to
invest time for this process
how do you convince and convert ceos
towards this process
um yeah so okay so i think that they're
three kinds of ceos okay
they're the ceos who make things happen
they're the ceos who follow things as
they happen and their ceos who wonder
what happened
okay what i mean is that that businesses
are always evolving
covet has accelerated the rate of change
immensely
and i believe that that the if it hadn't
been for the jss being extended to march
we would see a huge amount of
consolidation in singapore and enthalpy
because it is changing the whole
playbook
so i think any ceos who are wondering
whether or not
this is the right thing to do should
probably think again because it's
something that is
absolutely necessary because the
dynamics in singapore
and in industry are changing and we're
fortunate now to have been given a bit
of a respite until march next year where
we have the jss
because it allows us to say well let's
get this thing going right away while we
still have
that as a cushion don't wait until the
jss falls away it'll be too late
all right adrian do you have anything to
add to that not complicated
i think i think if you don't transform
your business now during copenhagen
um it's it's and i think i mean from a
government's perspective i can see that
it's quite clear it's it's really
looking we're giving you
some sort of time horizon now um and you
have the tools
you have the grants available um it's
it's you have to jump on board
uh and if you don't then you know you
might not be around anymore uh and that
that will be a little bit
unfortunate for some um but i think it
will be the reality and like steen said
it's just
accelerating the process right
um i'm building on a question that was
asked the scene earlier about uh
disney's uh magic team i'm curious what
what is your version of a magic team do
you have a version or is everybody the
magic team
what's it like for you adrian and steve
yeah we have a lot of magicians
um i think we were family business which
maybe is also a little bit different so
i think
you know my dad is no longer involved in
the day today we started the company
together but my sister handles a lot of
the marketing side and and
parts of the operation as well my
brother-in-law also especially on the
international side and so i think you
know we we complement each other very
well from sort of a senior management
level perspective
um but we also have people that have
been with us for the longest time so you
know 11 years
um they've been there for the first
outfit opening
we've sent people from here to open our
stores in hong kong so
i think people are definitely very
committed
um and they i mean we have a very open
culture so i think everyone um
you know understands they can share
ideas and we bring them into a lot of
the different
design thinking workshops that we even
do so and you know that can be
an auntie who has worked for us as a
part-timer in an outlet um
you know when we did our culture code
where we where we looked at you know
what what do we stand for as a company
in terms of our culture
um and uh and that that you know for
them is
hugely rewarding to be able to be part
of that so um
we we we're still very young i would say
we we know we're gonna be making
mistakes over the next few years
um but that's what also keeps us very
nimble and
and we have a lot of talent across we
hire from different industries as well
we very often do not hire from the f b
industry
uh and that that brings a lot of new
perspectives
all right thanks adrian yeah i i'm
hearing like you're going into data
analytics you know
uh digital cures and things like that
which are not traditional
fmb um capacities and capabilities but
that seems like the
the need right now for you yeah yeah
yeah how about you
well if i can do that i think what
adrian said is
is spot on but maybe a different way of
saying it is
you treat your staff as if they're
volunteers right
as if they're not getting paid to come
to work so so their pay is
job satisfaction how well they're
treated how much they're
allowed to grow in their jobs i always
try i can't claim i always succeeded
but i always said i would treat my staff
as if they are coming to work without
getting paid
and all i could give them is a great
place to work where they could grow or
they can thrive
in accordance with their ambitions
and then you will see things begin to
fly if people enjoy coming to work
everything will begin to to to to grow
got it um yeah uh
so we've got a couple of other questions
that uh
love to get answered before we close it
off
um one of it is
who should champion design thinking
obviously the ceo but are there other
key people you think within a business
that needs to champion that
to shift i'll give a very quick reply
because i tossed it a bit earlier but i
think
it needs to be championed by the ceo but
i think it's it's often because it's
consumer-facing
uh makes sense to have it led by
marketing as i say
brand is too important to be left to the
marketing people but they are good
to be the people who are moving things
forward they are good to be the owners
of that project so that would be my my
sort of two cents worth
yeah i agree and i think also the the
obviously the people on the ground
they're the ones that are dealing with
the issues that customers face
the different points of friction i think
we you know we
still find that constantly just to give
you a very small example
you know over the last few years we have
three delivery companies we have
odell we have so many different
third-party providers
that that you receive your orders from
that has created absolute havoc in
operations in singapore
you know you can imagine when you have
something like 10 tablets behind you
with a customer coming in sorry excuse
me i've got 10 orders
it's you know that that's a design
thinking process that
we never thought of five years ago but
we've had to adapt the team has to adapt
and they have their frustrations
customers their frustrations
how do you re-engineer that and
and improve that experience sometimes
with existing equipment and layouts that
you have or you can't change that
or it's not economically efficient to
change that so
that's just one small example on where
the team on the ground
uh you need to always obviously keep a
very close
gear for them okay
um thanks and and i think we don't have
much time left so i'll
end with this one question uh which is
what are the
experiences of having design thinking in
non-profit or non-business sectors you
know
like social service organizations what
do you think
is the biggest difference when compared
to the
profit and the business sector curious
for your perspective
um i'll have a crack at it first um
because i
the one thing that i would compare is
the public sector in singapore compared
to
other countries i've lived in but it is
second to none it is fantastic
the ease of doing business in singapore
or the ease of interacting with the
government
authorities as an individual is second
to none
so i have been impressed with with how
well thought through the public sector
is in singapore
with regard to how much emphasis it
places on
serving customers well it doesn't matter
where i call lta any or whatever there's
always someone picking up the phone
who's well spoken well educator can give
me an answer right away if not they
would definitely call back
so i think it's something that singapore
has has very deliberately and
intentionally
cultivated that the public sector is
there to serve the public and i think
it's a fantastic example of
of how well it can be done versus i
won't name any other countries but
i've worked in 50 countries around the
world where i haven't seen this level of
commitment to
customer satisfaction or whatever we
whether we call it since we are actually
not customers but we are
businesses or citizens
how about you adrian what's your
thinking around non-profit
um i think i mean even for
you know i think it is about still being
top of mind and
standing out so i think that you know
the brand and building that is still
fundamental i mean even if you're
not for profit and and your motives are
different i think
there's there's still fundamentally a
lot of parts of a of a user journey that
you need to look at
um and you know i think we luckily have
a lot of customers that are very
passionate about the brand we do a lot
with sustainability
um but that's also because we
we do it well like we you know we
actually provide an experience or
the communication channels to to do that
effectively
great well thank you steve uh really
enjoyed talking to you uh can i give
just one last
closing thoughts okay so give me give me
60 seconds okay because this is a
powerful example
um i used to travel to bangkok every
first tuesday of the month
to visit mcdonald's there i would
normally be on the same flight singapore
airlines coming in landing around 10 30
in the evening i would go to the hyatt
and i'd be there for two days
so my 30th trip as usual the concierge
is in the airport to greet me
uh as i come out of immigration he
guides me down to the to the limousine
in the limousine they say mr kun i have
my newspaper the cold water and so on
but here's what happens imagine now that
this car is pulling out
it's evening in bangkok they know that i
like to read
what was called the new york times
international hail tribute right it's
sitting there
and i pull it out but it's dark the
driver
checks the mirror sees i have the
newspaper turns on the light for me to
read
okay i was just about to ask him i read
the newspaper and he must have been
trained to listen for the folding sound
because as i thought the newspaper
he checks the mirror turns off the light
so the next day i had a chance to talk
to the hotel manager i said look what
what happened here i mean you know my
newspaper
i like the cold wars and so on but but
his amazing guy just turns on and off
like he said well
the customer journey which starts in the
airport
we went through every single touch point
and we said where can we
exceed our guests expectations and the
reason i share this is because i find
it immensely powerful but also for free
capable training attitude sense
hospitality
rather than well just given the
newspaper right so so these things
don't need to cost a lot of money and
while customers
like you to go the extra mile sometimes
going an inch
is enough because it's the attitude that
really counts so that would be my my
closing statement
for for things to for people so to
hopefully take away some good examples
of how little these things can cost
and that's a lovely example of dean and
it's really the
the beauty is really the details
and really making each moment of truth
count right um
uh adrian is there a closing thought you
want to leave to
the audience i just think i mean this
covid i think is is you know obviously
throw so many things up in the air but
i think for all of us it is also about
um
just taking a moment stepping back and
just looking at the process that we're
all
undertaking and and the transformation
and i mean it is so rapid i mean even
foster the slides i shared i mean
that almost seems like old news from
what we're working on right now
um but it's uh it's fascinating to see
that you know if you put your mind to it
and you have a team that is
thinking you know on the same wavelength
um you can achieve so much i mean we
really just have
you know seven or eight people in the
corporate office um and we get
to accomplish so many things um and i
think that kind of mindset of
always testing and and you know
communicating with your customers and
just being open-minded just brings you a
very long way so
i'm actually very excited about you know
what this company will look like next
year
uh and what we can also bring to other
markets because i think that you know
we're all going
through the same thing um we have
operations abroad that we worry about
but we also see great transformation
great thank you adrian yeah i think this
thing about uh iteration
and scene uh learning from me about
looking really into the details of each
touch point
and really being proactive to respond to
the
situation rather than just waiting for
kobe to happen i think those are really
good
um lessons to learn so i hope everybody
enjoyed this
session yeah and now i'll
pass it on to michelle back to you
thanks kaising can everyone see the
screen
yeah we hope everyone has enjoyed
today's uh webinar
um we'd like to thank all the speakers
who join us this morning as well as the
moderator
kai singh thank you so much thank you so
much adrian and as well as steen
and for everyone to join us today so you
wish to revisit today's discussion
and um and the content of today's uh
session the recording of the session
will be made available and shared to you
via email
also we'll love to know what you think
of the webinar at the end of this
session you'll be redirected to a link
so you can click on that link and then
help us fill up a short survey
so in the survey you can also help to
indicate uh what
which schemes you'll be interested to
find out more about
we love to share more with your company
and how we can get started on all these
design
thinking journeys if you wish to find
out more about programs that the
national design center has lined up for
the month of
august and september you can scan the qr
code on the right side
and finally i'd like to thank the
speakers again for collaborating with us
to make today's webinar
session possible it's been a pleasure
hosting this webinar with this
we want to wish everyone well and stay
safe and have a very pleasant day ahead
thank you